okay great thanks very much Teresa and
thanks also to [ __ ] and Ben and Ron and
the others who invited me it's great so
far it's a great venue so what I want to
talk about today is a new initiative
that we're trying to build critical mass
in and would love to involve anyone
who's interested it's easy to involve
you because right now it's just talk but
but hopefully I can convince you that
that it's describing what a lot of us
are already doing and furthermore that
maybe a lot of what we're talking about
here should be sort of focused and and
at least to the point where you can get
some visibility for it is sort of a
movement and so so far we're calling
this the cancer cell map initiative and
it's it does involve some some starter
funding it involves my collaborator
Nevin Croghan at UCSF our Cancer Center
director is both at UCSD and UCSF and
again we're trying to sort of get some
critical mass I also found out today by
reading the news that is apparently
World Cancer day so it's a good day to
be talking about cancer but what I want
to talk about is what I think a lot of
us have been talking about which is what
to do now so later you guys can tell me
what this number really is in terms of
is it 10,000 genomes we now have is it
exomes genomes what's you know what's
the difference how many is it really but
I think we all agree that not only do we
have a lot of genomes there's certainly
a lot more to come when it comes to
cancer may be hundreds of thousands of
more to come in the near future if if
what you hear is true so what are the
challenges as all of us or most of us in
this audience appreciate and have been
talking about at this meeting one of the
biggest challenges that becomes
immediately apparent after looking at
these cancer genomes and it's pointed
out by all of the papers is that most
tumor mutations are rare and that is to
say each patient is a snowflake they're
somatic alterations are completely
different from patient to patient now
this is our version of what other people
are drawn and called the long tail of
mutation certainly bill Han has talked a
lot
about this and I think has has laid this
point very effectively and so here's
here's a sort of a complimentary take on
that so if the goal there's different
goals one might have from from analyzing
cancer genomes certainly the ultimate
goal is to treat a patient properly but
in the meantime there's been a lot of
interest on can we identify all of the
cancer genes from from cancer genomes so
here's why I think not only can we not
but sequence until you're blue you're
never going to be able to and so here's
here's here's how that argument goes if
we take a random patient from the TCGA
this happens to be of the thousand or so
whole exome sequences that they've
they've elucidated and published this is
just one randomly drawn it's the first
one that I drew it's not carefully
chosen and we look at the somatically
alter genes in that patient or 25 of
them this happens to be actually below
the average for the cohort which is up
more towards 50 and now we plot on the
y-axis here mutation frequency and the
the scaling here is just versus
background so one would be roughly the
expected mutation background of any gene
chosen at random and 50 would be 50
times that background on average over
the whole genome you now see this
exponential tail where there's
essentially a single gene in this
patient got a 3 that's found we're
currently over the breast cancer cohort
in fact is 50 times roughly more likely
to be mutated than the average gene in
the breast cancer cohort but then very
quickly as as the shows that falls off
so now when you're looking at the fourth
or fifth most frequently mutated gene in
the cohort that happens to also be in
this patient now you're actually beneath
what the current algorithms or
statistics can distinguish as being
significantly over currently mutated in
the cohort and in fact a off cited
example of this is Braca one which was
originally identified from gene linkage
studies in germline mutations in the
somatic space it actually is not
identified as a significantly mutated
breast cancer gene we of course know
it's important and then we've actually
labeled two other genes here which are
known cancer genes and breast cancer and
look at where they fall the others
aren't aren't well described so so this
line here is sort of our current power
with the current number of genomes and
methods at distinguishing one of the
cancer genes from the non and certainly
it is true that as you do more
sequencing this line is gonna fall right
now let's say you know around one two
three three and a half times background
this will push down as low as say 1.5
times the background mutation rates if
you sequence say a hundred thousand more
genomes you can look at that and we can
we can discuss that at length but the
point is the situation fundamentally
isn't going to change because half the
genes in this patient are so close to
the background mutation rate or even
below the background mutation rate and
you can think of reasons why functional
cancer genes because they say disrupt
key processes and normal cells might
might actually not be frequent events at
all
you're never gonna access this this half
the tail there's just no way to do it
and so the question is is are these
important cancer genes or are they not
so to look at that what what we did is
go to this popular Sanger cancer gene
census you can look at the focal stain
list you can look at any number of lists
and the conclusions are qualitatively
the same so just bear with me on on this
particular list if you look at the
cancer gene census it's about 500 genes
that are say hand curated we can argue
about if the curation is liberal or
conservative but but it's a gene set
that's thought to be associated with
cancer and now what's interesting is if
you if you mind back into PubMed the
first citation of that is a cancer gene
for each of these genes that's not
something they've done that's something
my my former student Matt on how free
did you find that that about 10 percent
just over 10 percent have been in fact
found through tumor genome sequencing
and have been recently put in that
database but the other vast majority
were found by a collection of other
mostly functional approaches so you can
see here the big winner is is is
knockout mice and other other Nakia
knockout types of
in animals and cell lines as the way of
first demonstrating a cancer gene
many of these have indeed been
rediscovered in sequences but I think
it's important to realize that most of
the genes we consider cancer genes have
not been found by by sequencing sequence
based enrichment kinds of approaches so
to look a little further at this we took
a collection what we hoped was a broad
collection of methods that had been
proposed to analyze tumor genomes to
find cancer genes I hope most people's
tools are run here but I'm sure that
some have been left off we apologize in
advance but nonetheless it gives you a
sort of representative look at the
performance currently of the methods
that have been proposed or used
popularly especially to to identify
cancer genes and so what what no one has
ever done before all of these approaches
focus on essentially precision how good
are they at recovering those known genes
and they're actually many of them are
quite good okay notice that we're
clustering up here in terms of just
reading and and we're not in most cases
rerunning these algorithms in some cases
we had to mostly we're just looking at
the Supplemental table that that
algorithm publishes so you can see they
do quite well at finding cosmic or a
Sanger Center cancer genes but quite
poorly generally in recall even when you
put them all together you you can push
up recall but of course at the expense
of precision so this is the state of
affairs and and we're nowhere near of
course where where you want to be in
terms of finding cancer genes also
apologies to like Ben Raphael here
he never proposed hotnet as the cancer
gene identifier but we just kind of came
up with a trivial way in which it does
identify new cancer genes and maybe it
could be made better but but just to
give us a sort of feel for things so so
I I think a debate needs to be had not
just about what you do after you find
the cancer genes but whether genome
sequencing can even find the cancer
genes in the first place that's the
statement I'd like to propose for later
discussion let's point one for a later
discussion so so these observations for
us and I think I from you know this
conference clearly many of you
have have led us to conclude that that
we really need further information
beyond the genome sequences alone of
course genome sequences are required but
but we think they need to be
supplemented with information about
other aspects of cancer cell biology
which these days are mostly captured in
the so called genetic network or
molecular networks so the point of the
cancer cell map initiative would then be
like all good geneticists we're trying
to connect you know type to phenotype
ultimately to response to therapy and
disease diagnosis of an individual
patient but rather than go directly from
from genes to to phenotype as as you're
essentially trying to do when you look
for recurrent mutations in cancer let's
go through a middle layer which would
summarize cancer cell biology as we know
it and our current best representation
of that is a network model although at
the end of my talk I want to question
that and so so the cancer cell map
initiative then has sort of two prongs
one how do we accumulate this network
knowledge in the first place and can we
do it systematically much like genome
sequencing to systematically put
genotypes into the public domain and I'm
not going to talk early at all about
that that's been the purvey of my
collaborator Nevin croghan who's using
mass spectrometry based approaches now
to systematically go after some of these
cancer genes there's a many or a
multitude of other approaches one could
apply that we should talk about but
given the time I have I want to talk
more about this this orthogonal idea of
once you have network information in the
public domain that's a more systematic
or increases in how systematic that
network information is what do you do
with it and how can you use it in
translation of genotype to phenotype so
what I'm going to just briefly touch on
because it's it's an older paper now
last time I presented this Ben said god
it's a 2013 paper right you know and
he's right so I'm just going to just
refer you to the paper but but I guess
the reason why I still talk about it is
I'm so excited about it I guess and and
I still think it it points the way to
maybe some future studies into how you
do this but please do check out this
paper the basic idea is given network
knowledge okay you can now start to find
recurrence at the level of networks as
opposed to the level of genes certainly
hot annette pointed this out earlier
using network propagation here
essentially what we've done is we've
rotated this matrix and instead of
clustering mutations and networks the
focus is to cluster patients using the
the propagated value so we we propagate
mutations over a network such that now
instead of patient being represented by
a one for the genes that are altered and
a zero otherwise or some may be
functional score for the genes that are
altered but most most genes not being
altered right it's a sea of zeros and a
few few nonzero values after network
propagation what you get for each
patient is more of an information-rich
profile where essentially every gene has
a non zero score representing its
proximity to mutations in the network so
so just the raw mutations get
transformed to proximity to mutations
and that's what network propagation does
that's what others like been of use
certainly Road ed sheeran I think is the
first maybe to use that in
bioinformatics too in a paper earlier
from his group so so there's nothing new
algorithmically other than the way we're
applying this propagation tool to
transform a single patient's vector to
to a measure of network proximity to
mutations for each gene yeah
patience yeah so so actually this is
misleading this is the actual cluster
gram after you've done clustering the
data this is just showing that if you
try to cluster the raw alteration scores
for for whether a paid a gene is mutated
or not you essentially can't cluster it
it's not robust because essentially
every patient is different you have
maybe one or two features that are found
we're currently like p53 and can be used
to find clusters but those certainly
don't don't provide robust clusters
after the fact you can cluster the data
quite nicely is the idea for clustering
patients what's the observation yeah so
I'm getting there so so so the idea is
now you can take that patient by gene
matrix and cluster it you get robust
cluster is using bootstrapping or
consensus clustering in this case you
can see this effect with a variety of
networks maybe for a discussion later to
I would love to discuss what is the best
network we should all be using for this
kind of stuff I don't think it's any of
these by the way but let's let's I'm not
sure what it is but let's let's talk but
then here's here's some of the results
so here's cluster 1 this is the ovarian
TCGA cohort not that it doesn't really
matter for this sort of high-level
narrative but this is that cluster 1
this was the TCGA ovarian somatic genome
core or exome cohort this is the network
that supports cluster 1 so the idea here
is that every patient assigned of that
cluster mutates one of these genes
typically not more than one sometimes
it's more than one but typically one and
it's a different gene typically from
patient to patient that's shown here by
looking at these genes versus the
patient's except for Titan which which
is a whole story into itself but the
other genes in this cluster are
essentially getting hit once or twice in
the cohort but the important meme that
you're learning is that everyone in this
cluster gets hit somewhere on this page
and these clusters do in our hands
typically correspond to survival groups
which is an important validation so
here's the survival curves that you can
see that these clusters do stratify the
ovarian cohort by survival what what is
not published by us yet but it is
encouraging is in a more recent study of
ovarian cancer genomes coming out of the
ICGC we did not real earnest networks in
any way this is all unsupervised
analysis of TCGA but now we can take
that network we've discovered and use it
to classify new patients and in fact you
get the same exact stratification with
with patients hitting that aggressive
sub network I just showed you
now stratifying out by poor survival and
you can in fact look at the difference
between the TCGA cohort that was used
for the the discovery process of this
network and icgc cohort that was now
used to draw that second survival curve
which I guess you could call validation
this is that same network I to show it
it's just not pretty compared to that
last one it's the same connection
connections and genes and you can see
that really there are just a few genes
here four of them that are hid we're
currently in both cohorts but both both
cohorts are sort of just missing one
another in the same Network neighborhood
so it's pretty interesting and most of
these these colored nodes represent just
a single patient mutated neither TCGA or
Isis yeah so so that's a whole story in
and of itself we so the answer is for
some can't ovarian is is actually the
outlier we nothing we have done improves
or you know leads us to believe a that
these mutations are not functional or
that we could do better at finding these
mutations if we pre scored the function
so lots of people have suggested to us
and putting like all four of our
reviewers back in that 2013 paper that
rather than ones and zeros for what
genes are altered or not because we know
that you know in a sea of a hundred
mutations two exomes and a patient maybe
six are actually functional right so so
the theory that must be going on here
and we can show that these clusters are
not found if you randomized and all of
that right we can talk about all the
controls we've done we think we've
controlled for this
properly so so one would think that by
applying one of these functional scoring
algorithms to the hundred mutations in a
patient and propagating those scores you
might do better we actually have not
found that to be robustly the case in
fact for most every cancer but ovarian
we can throw out synonymous mutations
and that doesn't have any effect it
increases the signal slightly we find in
ovarian it turns out there's there's
been this argument that even synonymous
mutations effect expression levels and
that kind of thing and so we actually
don't even throw those out happy to talk
about it let me keep going because I
want to get to the second half of my
talk but it's really interesting and and
I I agree the jury is definitely not out
so let's let's let's trap but yeah there
is no requirement that it be if you
think about it all we're doing is
propagating that vector and clustering
the result and so the fact that it is
here so so let me now admit that that we
don't really know how to pinpoint the
right network here what you're looking
at is a heuristic happy so so I don't
think that's a salt problem I mean I can
tell you offline how I derived or helmet
on came up with this exact set of nodes
and edges and maybe you'll agree it's
reasonable but maybe not so let's let's
chat really what you want it's you know
in thinking about this is they're sort
of a basin of Attraction if I can use
that language for this subtype and so
there might even be nodes and edges or
nodes that could be mutated that have
not yet been observed in any patient but
nonetheless you'd want to put in this
thing because the prediction would be
it's in that basin of Attraction and if
you were to observe a patient say for
words simulate make up a patient and put
that patient in and run her genome
through then she would have to cluster
with this and we're not there yet
there's there's no node oh you the gray
nodes here are basically just connected
to the colored nodes they're in a very
trivial way and I'm not convinced to the
right
but approximately we think we got it
right not not exactly okay but let me in
the last 20 minutes of our to 10 minutes
of my talk I want to move to sort of
what we've now been spending our time
doing since since 2013 which actually
was not you you might have thought we
would have made progress in advancing
this method and in some way or other and
we're certainly interested in doing that
and I have a postdoc working on it but
our I think more encouraging results in
the past couple of years have come from
going back to model species like yeast
and looking at the process of what's
going here or happening here where you a
granade mutations and networks and
really try to ask whether this is the
right model at all and what I want to
argue is is maybe it was a better way of
doing it based not on networks but
hierarchies of the same information so I
want to first talk about this very
talented grad students work in my lab
like Mike Kramer for how you would
assemble hierarchical maps of components
and functions in the cell from network
knowledge and then pass this off to Mike
you another very capable grad student
and show you how he's then been using
these data-driven hierarchical maps to
aggregate mutations in much the way I
just showed you using networks so the
motivation here is that networks
generally don't look like the real
contents of cells when I draw the
network of say a Pentium chip I can
actually zoom into the Pentium chip and
find the wires when I draw a network of
say a brain I supposedly can find the
neurons and the axons and trace those so
it actually looks like a network these
hair balls we draw for cells don't look
like that they look like this this in
fact is the proteasome and this is what
the proteasome this is now in yeast I'd
warned you I'm going back to model
species for the rest of my talk this is
what the proteosome looks like in yeast
if I if I you know had shown you that in
a hairball diagram I have color coded
here the subunits of the proteasome so
you can see kind of how they lie and the
core here does kind of an a spring
embedded layout move
to the left and the regulatory subunits
of the proteasome do move to the right
this thing is a vacuum cleaner by the
way the tube is like that so you're kind
of looking at the side of the tube but
how do you get closer to this or at
least captures some key aspects of cell
structure and function that networks do
not capture and two of those key aspects
at least are modularity and scale so
here we see clusters of protein
interactions coming together in two
subunits of a protein complex but then
subunits assemble with other subunits to
make bigger subunits that say the red
part or the blue part and then that
entire thing makes up the proteasome I
can keep going upwards in cell structure
and function from here and say this is
part of protein degradation and so on
and so forth so how do we capture that
modularity and that scale so around the
same time of that 2013 Nature Methods
paper we had another paper which I think
would prove later to really converge
with-with-with or you know bring
together both ideas and that was this
this work by Janish Bukowski and my
group together with Mike Kramer and then
Kramer went on with with the Vinny
botanist lab to refine the algorithm but
the idea is that a lot of this
hierarchical multi scale modular
structure is actually present in these
Network hairballs if you look in the
right way to see that you cluster the
networks just like many clustering
algorithms have already been proposed to
do but as many of you know instead of
building a binary tree which is what
your standard agglomerative clustering
algorithm does you want to build a deck
why because you want the the
intermediate nodes of your clustering
dendrogram to reflect true structure in
the data as opposed to the binary tree
which is the computational convenience
and so for instance if these seven
proteins and the proteasome really
should be brought together at once
because they in fact are identical
subunits of a larger structure
why shouldn't you just merge them all at
the same time why force this thing into
a bunch of arbitrary binary decisions
which are just gonna be hard to
interpret biologically later because
they're meaningless by the same token
as we know there's pleiotropy and so
nothing constrains in the cell a a
protein or any module from being a
member of two or more parent modules and
so that also has to be respected when
you discover the cluster structure
inherent in the network data so then you
have a dag directed acyclic graph as
opposed to a binary tree here what
you're seeing is back in yeast we've
just clustered all information that one
can find in the public domain relating
to yeast protein protein interactions
co-expression interactions and synthetic
lethal interactions you then find that
this dag resembles to a large degree the
literature curated gene ontology so all
that great work the go is done over the
years also builds a gag but they just
decide when to create a term so if you
think about it all the computational
work with go has been bent on not the
dag structure itself that's assumed
given it's how you annotate new genes or
gene functions into that here were
actually less interested in that than
the structure of the dag itself that
said given the literature curated
reference map of a cell just like you
can have a reference genome this is now
the reference structure of a cell you
can now align that whole thing in a
one-to-one way not go in Richmond but a
one-to-one alignment back against the
dag you've created from data and every
time that you see a match and we can
talk about how these ontology alignment
algorithms work there's many of them
from computer science one can choose we
did not write our own that said there's
probably room for improvement we could
talk about when you find an alignment
then you can transfer any annotation go
put on that term over to your term and
equally or maybe more interestingly when
you do not find an alignment you might
have discovered a new component in the
cell here's what the thing looks like
yeah yes and no so we've we've addressed
that in a first-order way but there's a
nasty second-order way that it that I
can't know how to control for the
first-order way is yes there's
it's codes and you can use those to
remove evidence due to any data that you
think you've used but I'm not sure that
handles the following case let's say I
remove this gene annotated this term
because of protein in Tourette I don't
know
you know omics data but then that gene
actually interacts with another gene I I
don't know I I'm not making sense but
but I'm worried about second-order
effects here that that that you simply
can't take out by evidence codes but yes
we have taken out evidence codes for
what it's worth so here's what for yeast
are data-driven ontology which we called
Nexo looks like
and every time we label a term it's
again because we've got a good alignment
to go and so you can transfer that that
term annotation over and so so and this
is an I mean the the route is here it is
a rooted tree but it's not you know it's
not showing top-down so there's the root
and and you see very quickly this thing
trifer Cades into a membrane a
mitochondrion and an intracellular part
just let go so that maps over you can
also receive it and go your annotation
is much better for the components in the
intracellular compartment then for the
membrane or the mitochondrion which is
that you know that that just doesn't get
labeled and if you look go as
essentially very little structure
beneath those parts yet the data
suggests otherwise
so again just in passing and interesting
finding but then to zoom in just to kind
of show you low-level detail you'll
appreciate this fractal thing is a multi
scale structure like any hierarchy and
and so here Lu Zhu min to the proteasome
which is that that structure I showed
you before here I only had the hairball
now here's what it looks like in the
neck so data-driven oncology so it does
recognize that this whole thing is these
these proteins are clustered together so
that aligns it turns out to the
proteasome complex and go but then this
thing splits into a regulatory particle
in a core that's roughly the left and
right sides of this so you might have
picked that out by looking at the
hairball but then there's just no way
the algorithm can find further structure
that there's no way at least in this
visualization your eye can see
so the the regulatory particle has a
base
in a lid the core has an alpha and beta
subunit and then you're kind of at the
proteins so that's sort of the
alternative view of the same data that
we think might be a lot more useful
biologically than than this guy okay so
so the idea then is that maybe when you
look at these hair balls of interactions
you're just too close to the data you're
looking at the raw data sort of the raw
pairwise relations that have been pulled
out experimentally in various ohmic ways
and maybe that's sort of like you know
at one point people stared at these
x-ray diffraction images to get the
structure of DNA or structure of
proteins but now I'm not a structural
proteome assist but my understanding is
you kind of just assemble a million of
these images and you press the button
and you get that so maybe we just
haven't yet developed the right
algorithms that if not the full
structure of cell from omics data maybe
at least take you to an ontology and and
you know maybe maybe this is as far as
you can push it maybe not but but it's
it at least makes the point that maybe
maybe the hairball is just too too raw
okay so I I basically am out of time but
I just wanted to just quickly say that
that we think just to sort of pull this
back to the cancer interpretation of
genomes mode we think that the way these
ontology can then be used is to process
information and this is about to come
out so luckily you can read about it
instead of hearing me tell you about it
but but the idea now is is what we're
trying to do is to percolate genotypes
now here we're in yeast so you typically
have one two or three mutated genes and
the rest are blanks but you cannot
percolate these down through the
ontology and translate a genotype to
what we're calling a non toe type which
is just some instead of a set of genes
that are altered it's sort of like a set
of go terms or in this case next so
terms that are altered and you can then
use those as features for prediction of
phenotype it's working really quite well
I'll be happy to talk about it offline
but let me
instead get to the end of my talk and
you know summarize so here is sort of
the overall system you have a genotype
it's raining mutations down on your cell
but your cell is organized
hierarchically and so you can think
about each component in that
hierarchical map is like a funnel that
catches some number of mutations
builders it through the function of that
component and then passes on that
information to the next layer and and so
I think this might be sort of a new and
interesting way mostly is yet to be
explored for how you might connect unit
types of phenotype thank you